"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Quand on est de Verdun, comme vous,
pourquoi
on s'intéresse à l'Afrique ?
-J'ai pas de passé africain
dans ma famille.
Ni d'une manière ni de l'autre,
contrairement
aux collègues
qui travaillent sur l'Afrique.
Mais voilà.
J'ai rencontré à Nancy,
qui était la ville de Lyautet,
en prépa des étudiants marocains
qui étaient là
comme une forme d'héritage.
On a sympathisé.
Ca a commencé comme ça.
-Lyautet
figure de la colonisation française,
au Maroc.
-Oui.
-Comment expliquez-vous...
Beaucoup sont passionnés
par l'Afrique.
Comment vous expliquez
cette passion française ?
-Il faut remonter
au début du 19e siècle.
La France était tournée
vers l'Europe.
Elle a fait des guerres en Europe.
Et puis elle a perdu ces guerres,
à partir de 1814-1815.
Ensuite, elle a assisté à la montée
de l'Allemagne, la Prusse,
puis l'Allemagne.
Elle s'est tournée
vers l'Afrique
et a investi toutes ses forces,
qu'elles soient politiques,
militaires,
religieuses, intellectuelles.
Une grande partie de ses forces
y ont été investies.
Deux siècles après,
on en est toujours là.
Il y a eu le retour de bâton
de la décolonisation,
et la construction européenne,
mais affectivement,
l'attrait de l'Afrique persiste.
-Il y a une nostalgie
de cette période aujourd'hui ?
-De la période coloniale ?
-Oui.
-C'est difficile à dire.
Non, la page a été tournée.
Aujourd'hui, on regarde ça
comme un choix inadapté,
qui a attiré beaucoup
de problèmes à la France.
La Ve République
est née dans un contexte effroyable.
Il n'y a pas de nostalgie,
mais en revanche y a une histoire.
-Vous connaissez
particulièrement bien,
vous y avez vécu et enseigné,
l'Afrique du Nord.
Egypte, Maroc,
la Tunisie.
Y a plusieurs Afriques.
Cette Afrique
que vous connaissez bien,
elle est assez lointaine
de l'Afrique noire ?
-Ah oui.
En Afrique du Nord,
y a même l'Egypte,
qui à elle seule
constitue un monde à part.
Même la vallée du Nil,
à soi seule, c'est un monde.
Et il y a l'Afrique du Nord
arabo-berbère,
de la Lybie jusqu'au Maroc.
C'est une île, en arabe, on dit :
"al-Djazirat al-Maghrib".
C'est l'île du Maghreb.
Les Berbères l'appellent
"Tamazgha". C'est un monde en soi
entre la Méditerranée
et l'océan saharien.
Elle est coupée du reste.
Bien sûr,
les liens sont permanents,
avec le sud subsaharien
et avec l'Europe, la Méditerranée.
Mais ça constitue un monde à part.
-Les relations
ont été marquées parce qu'on
appelle la traite orientale.
C'est-à-dire l'esclavagisme
pratiqué par les Arabes,
avant la traite occidentale.
On en parle quasiment jamais.
Comment vous expliquez ça ?
-Y avait 5 grandes routes
qui reliaient
l'Afrique subsaharienne
à l'Afrique du Nord
et à la Méditerranée.
Certaines passaient
effectivement par l'Afrique du Nord.
Par le Maroc actuel,
l'Algérie, la Lybie.
Les routes se terminaient
dans les capitales
et les marchandises,
les humains partaient
dans l'Empire ottoman,
vers Istanbul,
ou restaient sur place.
C'est une histoire
dont on parle peu
parce que la plupart des descendants
ont disparu.
La plupart des hommes
ont été castrés.
Contrairement aux Etats-Unis,
y a pas de descendance.
Y a pas de peuple afro-descendant
de cette histoire en fait.
Bien sûr certaines personnes
ont fait souche,
notamment les femmes.
Elles sont rentrées
dans la société,
mais c'est occulté,
parce qu'il n'y a pas de témoins.
Ceux qui en parlent,
ce sont parfois les Africains,
notamment les Sénégalais
qui ont écrit là-dessus.
Y a des travaux. Cheikh Anta Diop...
-Grand historien sénégalais.
-Au Maghreb,
au Maroc, en Algérie, en Tunisie,
y a aussi des historiens
qui s'y sont intéressés.
Notamment au Maroc.
Mais ça reste un sujet complexe.
Parce qu'au fond,
tout ça a été gommé
par la période coloniale
et les rapports avec L'Europe,
et la France en particulier.
-Mais y a encore
des subsistances
de cette forme d'esclavagisme,
même si c'est pas la même chose,
notamment en Mauritanie,
où il y a encore
ce genre de pratiques
qui sont visibles.
-En Mauritanie,
dans d'autres pays du Sahel.
Aussi en Arabie Saoudite.
Ces pays n'ont jamais rompu
officiellement...
Enfin, officiellement, si.
Notamment sous la pression
des Britanniques ou internationale.
Le problème, c'est que
la colonisation a été le vecteur
qui a stoppé l'esclavage.
-La colonisation européenne.
-Elle a mis fin à cela. Ce n'est pas
venu de l'intérieur des sociétés.
Y a pas eu un mouvement
comme y a eu en Europe,
un mouvement libéral qui s'est
construit contre l'esclavagisme.
Il a été imposé par les Européens
de l'extérieur.
Ca été considéré comme
un "acte de violence coloniale".
Donc, le bien peut recouvrir
le mal, ou l'inverse.
A la fin, on en parle pas beaucoup,
mais ça reste très puissant,
car cette traite
a été plus importante
que la traite transatlantique
et elle a duré plus de 1000 ans.
12 ou 13 siècles,
donc c'est considérable.
-Vous êtes d'accord
avec Aimé Césaire :
"Y a pas un devoir de mémoire,
"y a un droit à l'Histoire."
-L'esclavagisme
est un bon exemple
pour parler de l'Histoire.
Car il n'y a plus de mémoire.
Qui se rappelle avoir eu
des parents,
grands-parents esclaves ?
L'Histoire est là
aussi pour rappeler
les faits.
Pour faire justice
et oeuvre de vérité surtout.
La mémoire, c'est affectif.
On prend nos relations
sur le Maghreb
sur le mode de la mémoire,
mais on s'en sortira
en écrivant l'Histoire,
qui est déjà écrite, heureusement.
On essaie d'y contribuer.
Mais c'est ça qui permettra
d'avoir à l'avenir
des relations saines.
Tant qu'on est dans le contentieux,
dans l'affectif,
dans le revanchard,
la tension liée
à toutes les pulsions
et les passions humaines,
on est dans une logique
d'affrontement.
L'Histoire est un facteur de paix
et de pacification.
-En Afrique, les Etats se vivent-ils
comme des nations ?
-Certains.
Y a des très vieilles nations.
La Tunisie, le Maroc,
l'Ethiopie, l'Egypte.
Dans ces pays très anciens,
y a pas de problème.
Dans d'autres qui ont eu
une histoire forte au 20e siècle,
que ce soit l'Algérie ou le Sénégal,
je pense que
y a pas de problème non plus.
Y en a d'autres.
Il y a plus de 50 Etats africains.
-50 pays, oui.
-En revanche, pour prendre
le cas de la Lybie,
qui n'est pas très éloignée,
la question de l'Etat
ne fait pas la nation.
Ca vient de loin,
les Kadhafi et ses prédécesseurs
n'ont jamais construit une nation.
Elle n'existe pas.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
les Etats faillis.
Y en a d'autres,
notamment au Sahel.
Le Soudan a éclaté
y a quelques années.
Des Etats de la bande sahélienne
sont très fragiles.
Y a deux processus.
Y a l'Etat
qui est parfois quasiment disparu.
Aujourd'hui, en Lybie,
on sait pas si y a 2 Etats.
-La Cyrénaïque,
et la Tripolitaine ?
-Et le sud à moitié autonome,
ça fait 3.
Et puis la question de la nation.
Pour qu'il y ait une nation,
il faut une aventure
collective, durable,
avec une mémoire,
une histoire écrite, enseignée.
Une Nation, ça se forge.
Quand ça dure
depuis plus de 3000 ans,
comme la Chine, c'est facile.
Quand c'est récent
qu'on n'a pas mis les outils,
que l'Etat est faible et ne peut pas
inculquer cette histoire
la nation n'existe pas.
L'Afrique est partagée
entre les deux.
-Souvent, on entend,
notamment les Africains,
qui disent...
Cette conférence de Berlin...
Elle a eu lieu
à la fin du 19e siècle,
en 1885, à la demande
de Bismarck. Les Européens
se sont partagé l'Afrique.
Ils disent : "Les Européens ont fait
des frontières artificielles."
Ya une part de vérité.
-Oui, quand on voit
ces frontières au cordeau.
Y a pas eu de recherche
de cohérence,
à l'intérieur même
de l'ensemble colonial français.
On aurait pu imaginer
des rassemblements
faits sur des bases
liées à l'environnement,
à la nature,
aux reliefs, aux massifs.
Ca a été fait sur d'autres bases.
Autour d'une capitale,
on a tiré un cercle.
C'est très administratif,
militaire, bureaucratique.
Le principe fondateur de l'OUA,
à l'indépendance de l'Afrique...
-L'Organisation
de l'Unité Africaine.
-Devenue Union Africaine, c'est
ne pas toucher aux frontières.
C'est un principe
qu'on peut entendre,
sauf que les frontières ont bougé.
On parlait du Soudan.
-Soudan du Sud, Soudan du Nord.
-L'Erythrée aussi,
ça a été un précédent.
-Qui est sortie de l'Ethiopie.
-Le principe est plus fragile
qu'il n'y paraissait.
Ca reste un principe
auquel un certain nombre d'Etats
sont très attachés.
Mais évidemment,
ça ne correspond pas
à des réalités culturelles,
voire religieuses, ou ethniques.
D'où le fait que seul l'Etat
peut construire une nation,
que ce soit par la guerre
ou le football,
mais c'est pas toujours facile.
-On oppose souvent
les colonisations les unes
aux autres,
sans remonter
à la colonisation arabe.
Mais les colonisations
britannique et française,
y a de réelles différences ?
Une colonisation "civilisatrice"
chez les Français,
beaucoup plus commerciale
chez les Britanniques, non ?
-On peut le dire comme ça.
Encore que, regardez la puissance
de la langue anglaise
dans les anciennes
colonies anglaises.
Elle est très forte.
-Kenya, Ouganda...
-Elle est pas contestée
comme la francophonie aujourd'hui.
L'assimilation à la française,
c'est une assimilation
de territoires,
notamment de l'Algérie,
des communes du Sénégal.
C'était pas une assimilation
à la culture des peuples,
car l'école a été distribuée
avec une extrême parcimonie.
C'était l'assimilation
d'une partie des élites.
Pour le reste,
le mode de gouvernement
a été inventé en Algérie
au 19e siècle.
Il était identique
à l'"indirect rule",
c'est-à-dire gouverner un pays
avec peu de moyens humains,
matériels,
par le biais des élites
traditionnelles
avec lesquelles on s'entend,
soit après la guerre,
soit la négociation immédiate.
Avec un échange de bons procédés,
des terres, des impôts,
des femmes, des fonctions,
des médailles, etc.
Donc cette base-là n'a pas préparé
les peuples de la région
à une forme d'assimilation,
en tout cas d'acculturation.
C'est après,
c'est les gouvernements indépendants
qui ont créé
l'école à la française
et qui ont diffusé
la francophonie en Afrique.
-Contrairement à tout
ce qu'on peut lire et dire.
-Y compris au Maroc et en Algérie.
-Vous remettez en question
les préjugés qui circulent.
-Parce qu'on a appris aux Africains
"Nos ancêtres, les Gaulois".
Mais y a 2 % des Africains
qui ont entendu ça.
Les autres
ne sont pas allés à l'école.
Ce sont les gouvernements
aux indépendances
qui ont été séduits par le modèle.
Ils voulaient diriger le modèle
au lieu de le laisser
aux mains des Français
qui étaient peu nombreux.
L'indépendance
leur a confié le pouvoir.
La 1re chose qui a été faite
dans la quasi totalité des pays,
ça a été de créer
un système scolaire francophone,
très proche
pour ne pas dire identique
au système mis en place
sous la colonisation.
Avec une africanisation, parfois,
de l'histoire et de la géographie.
La francophonie est un phénomène
qui est post-colonial
en Afrique.
On le sait plus aujourd'hui.
3 générations après, c'est oublié.
-Comment vous expliquez que
ce qui réunit les anciennes Nations,
les anciennes colonies britanniques,
a plus de corps que
justement la francophonie
qui n'a jamais eu une place énorme
dans les relations internationales ?
-La France coloniale
est passée après l'Angleterre.
Ou alors elle a perdu
ses principaux fleurons
au 18e siècle.
Je pense à l'Inde.
Et je pense à l'Amérique du Nord,
Notamment au Canada.
Elle est passée après.
Elle s'est approprié
des territoires
délaissés par les Britanniques.
Des territoires soit sous-peuplés,
soit très pauvres.
Je pense au Sahara, ou au Sahel.
Y avait des peuples,
des civilisations, des villes.
Mais c'était des territoires
très pauvres.
Et la France a investi
très peu de moyens humains,
parce que la colonisation
est contemporaine de la transition
démographique en France.
Y avait personne
à envoyer aux colonies.
-Personne ne voulait y aller.
-On envoyait des fonctionnaires
et des militaires de force.
Quelques religieux.
Mais personne ne s'est installé
en Indochine, en Afrique.
L'Algérie, ça reste
notre "colonie de peuplement"
avec un million d'habitants
à la fin.
-Un million d'Européens.
Dont une majorité était
soit d'origine algérienne,
ou européenne - espagnol, italien.
Donc à la fin,
y a 400 000 Français d'origine
qui sont installés en Algérie.
Quelques 100 000 à peine
au Maroc et en Tunisie.
Et puis quelques dizaines
de milliers.
Ca a été l'affaire
des élites françaises.
C'était l'affaire
du milieu commercial,
politique et militaire français.
Les Français ont découvert
les colonies, non en s'y rendant....
Les Britanniques
y allaient en bateau par millions,
notamment les marins, etc.
Mais quand les troupes coloniales
ont débarqué en France en 1914.
C'est pas l'histoire
telle qu'on la...
-Les fameux tirailleurs sénégalais.
-Et algériens.
-On a l'impression que tout ça
n'est pas su, n'est pas connu.
On oscille entre
une vision irénique,
écrite beaucoup par les Français,
ou une vision
de remise en question
qui aujourd'hui va loin,
car on parle de la woke culture
de cette négation de l'Histoire.
On réécrit l'Histoire
sans la connaître vraiment.
-On en fait
un programme idéologique.
Un objet de lutte idéologique.
-C'est grave, ça, non ?
-C'est grave du point de vue
de l'Histoire et des historiens.
Car la politique et l'idéologie,
c'est pas l'Histoire.
-C'est aussi
un apprentissage de la haine.
-C'est le rôle de l'idéologie.
C'est le rôle de la politique
de scénariser
des conflits imaginaires.
Le discours idéologique
met du sel sur les plaies,
raconte des choses fausses.
Aujourd'hui, sur l'histoire
de la colonisation de l'Afrique,
on est aux prises à tout un tas
de mensonges très grossiers.
Est-ce que les gens les disent
parce qu'ils ne lisent pas,
et qu'ils s'en tiennent
à des discours caricaturaux
ou volontairement ?
Ou bien est-ce un combat
politique et idéologique,
ou c'est de l'ignorance ?
Mais on gagnerait
à enseigner ces choses-là,
et en France, on a beaucoup de mal
à enseigner cette Histoire,
parce qu'on pense
qu'elle est polémique,
alors qu'elle est pacificatrice.
-Un sujet polémique,
c'est le face-à-face
franco-algérien
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à aborder
de part et d'autre
de la Méditerranée,
de façon apaisée.
C'est infernal, cette histoire.
-Elle est devenue
infernale, elle ne l'était pas.
Dans les années 60-70,
la relation était apaisée.
-Juste après l'indépendance ?
-Oui, y compris
de la part de Boumédiène.
-C'était le 2e président algérien,
après Ben Bella.
-Ils avaient gagné la guerre.
Les gens qui ont gagné la guerre,
ils sont en général assez contents.
D'autant plus que cette guerre
paraissait ingagnable.
Au bout de 8 ans
d'une guerre très dure...
-1954-62.
-Elle a été gagnée.
Quand on lit les discours,
les textes,
des années 60-70,
y avait la fierté
d'avoir gagné cette égalité
qu'avait été réclamée
si longtemps aux Français
qui avaient professé l'égalité
sans la donner.
La décolonisation, en Algérie,
qui était la France
juridiquement depuis 1948,
l'idée était d'obtenir l'égalité.
Et finalement, l'indépendance
a offert l'égalité.
Euh... Etatique, intellectuelle,
l'égale dignité, etc.
Pourquoi les choses ont vrillé,
ont tourné ?
Parce qu'on est dans la mémoire,
dans le refoulement,
dans la mémoire qui saigne,
comme a dit Stora.
On est aussi dans les lendemains
de la guerre civile
algérienne des années 90,
qui a durci les positions.
Et qui a fait réviser
les élites algériennes,
elles ont complètement révisé
leurs positions.
Et une partie des élites françaises
se sont saisi de cette Histoire.
C'est la guerre occultée, la guerre
civile algérienne des années 90.
Y a pas de livre, pas d'historien,
pas de film, pas d'image.
-C'est une guerre civile, interne.
-Une guerre civile très dure
entre le pouvoir algérien
et les islamistes,
et en sortant de ça,
Bouteflika a repris
la guerre d'Algérie
pour en faire un objet
de contentieux avec la France.
Ce que ce n'était pas
dans les années d'après-guerre.
C'est le grand paradoxe.
-Si on revient à la colonisation
juste avant l'indépendance de 1962,
est-ce que Charles de Gaulle
qui a jamais cru
au fait que la France
pouvait coexister avec l'Algérie
qui était une colonie
avec 3 départements, Oran, Alger...
-Assimilés au territoire national.
-Constantine.
Comme si on était
dans le Gers ou le Lot.
Est-ce qu'il n'avait pas raison,
De Gaulle,
en disant :
"C'est injouable,
"on peut pas coexister,
on peut pas cohabiter,
"c'est pas possible."
-Au 19e siècle,
on a fabriqué un mensonge.
La IIIe République a dit :
"On assimile."
"On assimile l'Algérie
mais sans son peuple.
Et ça a été payé...
-Urbain.
Un inspirateur de Napoléon III
qui était exactement
pour ce que vous êtes
en train de dire.
-Métis antillais.
Conseiller de Napoléon III...
-Guyanais d'origine.
-... et de la politique
du Royaume arabe de Napoléon III.
On a fabriqué ce mensonge
et il a fallu un siècle
pour en sortir.
De Gaulle a décidé d'en sortir.
Mais le mensonge était total.
Vous dites d'un côté aux Français :
"L'Algérie, c'est la France.
"C'est comme l'Auvergne
ou la Bretagne."
Et de l'autre,
y a une population qui est là, qui
vit selon les lois de la France,
mais à côté dans les montagnes,
dans les hauts plateaux,
dans les petits coins,
y a un peuple
de plusieurs millions de personnes
qui, certes, sont françaises,
mais sujets français,
qui n'ont pas
la citoyenneté française,
qui ne vont pas
beaucoup à l'école,
qui n'ont pas vraiment
de secteur économique.
L'industrialisation de l'Algérie
a commencé
pendant la guerre d'Algérie.
La scolarisation,
après la 2e Guerre mondiale.
Y a eu plus d'investissements
en Algérie
pendant la guerre d'Algérie
que pendant la période coloniale.
Au dernier moment,
De Gaulle se dit :
"Avant de partir,
il faut quand même
"donner les moyens
à ce pays de vivre,
"et ne pas sombrer
dans l'hostilité à la France."
Le problème, c'est la IIIe
République qui a fabriqué ça.
-Et les islamistes sont arrivés.
C'est une espèce d'idéologie
qui a complètement changé la donne
et les rapports entre
l'Occident et les pays arabes.
-Il vient de loin.
Il a été inventé en Egypte
à la fin du 19e siècle,
dans une forme libérale,
appelée la salafia ou la réforme,
par comparaison aux protestants.
Et il y a une radicalisation
qui s'est faite
à la fois par les Saoudiens,
par les wahhabites saoudiens
et les Frères musulmans en Egypte.
Tout ça remonte
au début du 20e siècle.
Et ça a maturé...
Ca a cuit...
Ca a confit dans les sociétés
notamment d'Afrique du Nord,
et du Moyen-Orient.
Ils le présentent comme
la décolonisation culturelle.
Les Etats ont obtenu
la décolonisation politique,
et nous, on va pratiquer
la décolonisation culturelle.
C'est comme ça qu'on a vendu
l'islamisme aux Français.
En parlant
de reconquête identitaire.
Sauf qu'on le voit en Algérie,
la reconquête identitaire se tourne
contre leurs dirigeants,
d'où la guerre civile algérienne,
très violente,
qui a été le 1er djihad
contemporain.
Depuis on en a eu d'autres
en Moyen-Orient.
Y a une tentative
de prise du pouvoir
par un islam politique
extrêmement intolérant.
Et qui n'est pas neuf. On a eu
des précédents historiques.
Il est à la fois éradicateur,
révisionniste,
et qui veut n'avoir qu'une tête.
Le refus des minorités,
de toutes diversités,
de tout processus démocratique,
et installer le règne
de Dieu sur Terre.
C'est ce qu'on a appelé
la hakimiyyah :
y a même pas besoin de gouvernement,
pas besoin d'Etat,
Dieu gouverne directement
sur Terre les hommes, etc.
Lors d'élections,
il est rare que les islamistes
aient plus d'un tiers des voix.
Mais à partir de ce tiers, ils ont
réussi à renverser des sociétés.
On est dans une forme
d'impasse aujourd'hui.
-Est-ce dû au fait qu'il n'y ait
plus d'homme fort ?
Nasser dans les années 50
qui sort d'un rendez-vous
avec les Frères musulmans
en Egypte,
et ils lui demandent
d'imposer le voile
dans la société.
C'est pas très bien daté,
mais c'est un peu avant le pouvoir.
Au début des années 50.
Et il est mort de rire,
en disant : "Ils m'ont demandé
que vous portiez le voile !"
Evidemment, il refuse.
Y a Nasser,
grand bonhomme, Bourguiba.
C'était quand même
des nationalistes très opposés
à la colonisation
mais qui n'étaient pas
mais pas dans la religion.
-Ces grandes figures
du milieu du 20e siècle,
ils ont eu leur popularité
parce qu'ils ont obtenu
l'indépendance,
parce qu'ils ont eu
un discours modernisateur,
parce qu'ils ont voulu créer
des Nations modernes,
promettre l'école,
le développement à tous.
Et ils ont entraîné leur peuple,
avec une passion incroyable
dans le cas de Nasser.
Mais les promesses
du régime nassérien
n'ont pas été tenues.
Il avait les moyens
de développer l'Egypte,
mais il a fait la guerre au Yémen,
la guerre à Israël.
Enfin, il l'a subie
et il en a fait une seconde, même
si c'était Sadate à ce moment-là.
L'Egypte s'est construit
comme un appareil militaire.
C'était la faiblesse de ces pays.
Bourguiba
n'a pas sombré dans le militarisme,
il s'en méfiait.
Mais c'était le pays
le plus pauvre de la région,
sans trop de ressources.
Lui aussi n'a pas eu les moyens
de faire cette politique.
Même s'il a empêché
l'explosion démographique
comme en Egypte,
voire comme en Algérie.
Donc voilà...
C'est cette malheureuse situation
de l'échec
de ce qu'on a appelé
le développementalisme.
Les Occidentaux, tout le monde
voulait le développement.
Les Tiers-mondistes aussi.
Il n'a pas eu lieu.
Ca a créé une situation,
une impasse.
Et on est dans cette impasse.
On en sortira, car il y a
beaucoup d'intellectuels,
dans la région,
en Tunisie, en Egypte,
au Maroc aussi, en Algérie,
qui font un travail remarquable
de clarification
idéologique, religieuse, politique.
Ils font le bilan du 20e siècle.
Mais il y a une temporalité décalée
entre les masses,
ce qu'enseigne l'école et ce que
pense un certain nombre de penseurs.
Il va falloir du temps
pour que ces idées règnent.
-Le mouvement hirak finalement,
il a débouché
sur une impasse.
C'est toujours le FLN
qui est au pouvoir.
-C'est ce qui s'est passé avec
les Printemps arabes en 2011.
On voit que l'aspiration
des peuples est là.
L'aspiration à la liberté,
à la dignité, à l'égalité.
Mais évidemment,
on est dans une période
difficile.
L'aggravation de la situation
économique internationale
n'est pas pour rien dans le fait que
ces difficultés soient entretenues.
-Une question.
Si vous aviez un livre
de littérature africaine
à recommander, quel serait-il ?
-Je pense à la saga
de Mouloud Mammeri.
-Oui...
-"L'Opium et le Bâton",
et d'autres
qui sont...
Ou "La Colline oubliée",
qui sont remarquables.
Ils écrivent
l'histoire des Algériens,
mais aussi une autre histoire.
C'est très bien écrit.
C'est pas traduit car il écrit
directement en français,
c'est souvent un avantage.
Il a un très beau style.
Et c'est de la grande littérature.
-Lisez Mouloud Mammeri. Merci
Pierre Vermeren !
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...